Ooh,
oh,
we live.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight and then you
enter in the code name Rogan,
you get 50% about 50.
The rest say 1515.
I'm not,
I'm not add new coupons folks.
I've just high 15% off the number one sex toy from Matt does.
Number one,
it was,
there was a fucking race apparently and the fleshlight one.
How did they,
how did they,
it's ridiculous I guess because they sell more.
You can just call yourself number one.
That must be what it is.
It's a solid product.
Don't get me wrong,
we're making fun of it,
but if you're going to masturbate and you're going to masturbate,
stop fucking around.
This is technology for masturbation.
It's an embarrassing purchase.
Indeed.
It's a fucking commitment,
but it is worth it.
It's fucking great.
Works,
works awesome.
Way better than your hand or your cat.
And uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o n n I t.com,
the makers of Alpha brain.
The cognitive enhancing supplement that a ice whereby I love the stuff and um,
you can find out about it online.
If you don't know too much about nootropics,
just Google it.
There's a bunch of different articles have been written on the subject and if
you're interested in an experiment on your own,
and like we always say if you like,
you know the idea behind Alpha brain but you think it's too expensive or what?
It just copied the ingredients,
go buy it in bulk,
mix it yourself.
I'm a much more interested in people not getting ripped off than I am in making
any money off this thing.
If you,
you don't like it,
you also get 100% money back guarantee.
It's real simple.
If you order it,
you say it sucks,
you get your money back.
I try to be as even as possible with this.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for Alpha brain,
you can get 10% off by entering the code name Rogan and you know there's also a
bunch of other cool shit that we have this new mood.
It is a five HTP,
serotonin boosting supplement that I really like.
And then there's a this quarter zips,
mushrooms supplement called shroom tech sport,
which is great for anybody who likes to really work out hard and it's got like a
lot of vitamin B 12 and in as well.
And together it's just a,
it's a really good,
like vigorous workout formula.
Brian does not need that shit though.
It makes me type faster.
Did it do anything for you?
Uh,
you know,
I haven't really tried that one yet.
That's the only way that I tried,
but I'm doing everything else and I really liked the immune.
That's my favorite.
Yeah,
the shroom tech immune is a really fascinating one because what it is is,
uh,
somehow or another,
I don't,
I don't know the total science behind it,
so I don't want to speak out of school.
But from what it's explained to me is the,
when you eat these mushrooms,
your immune system reacts to them as if they're like,
uh,
like,
like they've had,
there's an issue,
like there's a bacterial infection,
a cold or something,
but there is no cold.
So it jumps up your immune system so your immune system builds up this big crazy
army.
But then there's no war,
right?
So some other punks come along.
Your immune system is ready anyway.
That's the end of the commercials.
Hit The music bitch.
We got Everlast in the house today.
Come on son.
What's the name of this song I get by single off the new album ever last.
Grateful
God.
Oh man man.
Keep counting of my house.
Talking about our whole harassing mass.
Bow Scott.
My truck on a nother black cause the sub prime loan got my ass and hock got a
couple of grants.
Hell help as a need.
A brand new job with a health care plan they closed.
The plant is don't match APP until on the crown.
Don't pay unless you ask the math.
So small below
to try to kill.
Never seen them all by by them paying it.
No mind
they can't.
That's good shit.
Like loving man.
This is classic.
Gotcha video.
Where can you find the video
on Youtube?
Everlast music channel.
We only gave you a taste.
Ladies and gentlemen.
This is more of that song.
Obviously that's,
but you could tell that's classic shit.
That's you.
That's you and your groove man.
Yeah.
And you know what?
It's one of those cds I was talking about talking about this earlier,
that I buy cds and I usually like two or three songs.
It's just one of those cds where I honestly like every single song on STD and
there's a few of them that like my house,
I fucking love.
This is awesome.
It's been a while since he puts something out.
And so is it like couple years?
How many years has it been to clean?
I put a three so,
oh eight I put out the record.
He was like having like that kind of a space in between records where you really
get to work on your shit and really get to like put it in a form you like.
Yeah,
I got no choices.
Just songs come to me in groups and in bunches and then I,
I get caught up.
Just live in,
you know what I mean?
It's
just kind of,
I can't force an issue if I'm,
if I tried to write a song when I wasn't feeling like writing a song,
it would just be horrible,
you know?
I mean,
I've done it,
I've tried it,
you know what I mean?
It's just sometimes it's like life says don't write a record.
Right,
right,
right.
And I told her and I lay back and I,
I take my time.
I just,
I like taking in as much music as,
as,
as I do put,
putting out music.
So I listen to things.
I learned more about music.
Right.
Do you like,
um,
when,
when you write,
do you just say,
do you have like a whim?
Like it just comes across you like,
no,
I'm gonna sit down right now.
I started writing a song.
Like,
you don't have like a set aside time or anything.
Like what do you go,
I'm just going to work on music.
How does it work with you nowadays?
I just go,
you know,
I keep a studio away from the house,
just,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
and make it like a job.
Just go every day,
you know,
not,
not quite nine to five hours,
but try to keep it as respectful to the family and whatnot is,
you know,
before it was just,
yes.
I mean if it,
if I wanted to work at two in the morning and I work at two in the morning and
here,
I mean,
and that's still the case,
but it's,
I don't really live in that hour anymore.
Yeah.
I don't either.
But there's something kind of bad ass about that shit that comes out at like
4:00 AM.
Yeah.
You know,
that's why you can't,
you know,
can't not do it if it's,
if it needs to be done,
but I'm not sitting around it two in the morning waiting on it,
you know what I mean?
If,
if it jumps on me,
I'm,
I'm working on it.
But I always personally felt like it was right in anything that you don't get
into the real trance until like the whole house is asleep.
Oh yeah.
Until it's just you and the silence and the keyboard and then you get into the
real trance.
Well.
That's also why I keep a separate area.
Like,
you know,
I'm just talking about like a good hour away from the house.
I got to drive to go to the studio and I usually spend a day or two there and
you know,
just block my mind out of everything and try and you know,
it's,
there's no way so it could be two in the morning,
you know,
are you always writing shit down to like if you like a,
if you're looking at a restaurant or something,
you have an idea for something to do,
write it down and he just honestly never written an idea down ever.
Wow.
Not a lyric.
Got a rap lyric.
None.
She just keeps on your head.
Yeah.
Not a chord progression on an wow.
I can't remember it.
It's lost to the universe.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
There's something beautiful about that bad.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
I'm like a beautiful mind.
Kind of an idiot,
idiot savant,
you know?
No,
half the chords I play on the guitar,
man,
I've just copied them from other people and really holy shit.
It doesn't Jz do that as well.
He doesn't write any of his raps and leave.
So yeah,
that's incredible.
That's incredible.
So all your shit,
it just started for me as a,
as a,
as a way of exercising your mind.
When I was a young kid trying to be a rapper,
I was like,
you should always have it ready in your brain.
And then I,
my style of writing just became kind of visual.
And it's like in my mind when I write lyrics,
I have the pictures in my brain.
I equate it to that cat on Oz that drew pictures on paper.
But he was a poet,
you know what I mean?
It wasn't words.
It was always this picture.
But he would read it as a poem and it's almost the same thing.
It's three dimensional in my head,
a song,
the minute I would start writing the words out two dimensionally,
it would just lose all meaning and feeling to me.
Oh,
that's fascinating.
So you feel like the writing in a writing and in just a verbal and an audio way
is the way to do it?
Right.
It's just very dimensional for me.
Like in my mind it's like three dimensional pictures of,
of what I'm writing about and that totally,
the minute I committed them to paper and they're two dimensional,
I lose all it.
I hate,
I mean it's a despise will.
They'd go from something I'm really digging,
so let me write that down and see it and then I see it as a whole different
meaning.
It's not,
it's words,
it's paper.
It's,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
That's a fascinating
mind you.
I only put out a record every two or three years.
That's really interesting though,
but you're totally right.
Well,
there's some people that have just a way of expressing themselves that's like a
fun way to listen to.
I always bring up my friend Joey does.
Do you know Joey Diaz?
The comedian sounds familiar.
He's,
he's,
if you ever listened to the podcast,
he's on all the time.
He's one of my best friends.
He's this guy that is just,
he's,
the way he talks is just like poetry.
Right?
You know?
He's just like,
what's up dog?
What do we,
what is this party kicking motherfucker?
What are we doing?
Bitches?
He's given.
Everybody knocked goes and everybody's laughing and smiling or it just takes you
off in a wave.
And Joey Diaz is not something you could write down on paper.
That's a flavor.
That's a real live like,
as you said,
three dimensional flavor to the way his words come out.
It's alive.
It's,
you know,
it's surrounds me in my head.
If I'm writing it in my head,
it's all around me.
Why me?
I committed to paper.
It's just flat.
And so do you have a,
so if none of this is all written down,
do you have like a set list in your mind of how you put it in order in your
shows or do you wing it?
They'd go on on how you feel or not?
I'll write the titles down.
I W it's also become a superstition at this point in my life.
It's like after you make a record,
they want the lyrics.
You know what they want to know?
The publishing company is that's giving you money for what you written,
wants to know what you wrote.
But I actually,
I have to have one of my people,
my assistants,
like,
hey,
write the lyrics down and I'll sit there and dictate them to you because it's
become like a superstition at this
point.
Two.
Wow.
Have you ever tried to like break away from that?
Only let me see if I could just ride one star from scratch by writing it down.
I have and it's just,
again,
it's like I don't,
I live in a song until it's done.
You know what I mean?
Until it's finished.
It's all around me and said once it's on paper,
it's like,
well you hit some notes,
man,
you hit some notes in that.
What it's like song.
We're like,
whoa.
Like you know the one about the girl finding out she's pregnant,
the guy leaving and find that man again,
she's going to cut off his balls like you.
You hit that note and that note maybe wasn't something that would have ever been
the same if it was written down.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you,
you,
you hit it with the feeling of being that girl and that situation and it was
realistic and,
and,
and you know,
like alive three dimensional.
I mean there's trust,
there's times I wish I could take,
do that,
but like take that and write it on a piece of paper in a way that I thought was
beautiful and artistic.
Cause I'd love to write a movie but I can't do that.
I'm not,
I'm saying this thing about music and the way it lives in my head,
I don't really know how to make music,
man.
I've been faking it for a long time.
Dude.
I just been picking up things and making sounds that I'm like,
I like this sound,
I'm going to make this sound.
You know what I mean?
This thing way I can put it.
I mean I've learned along the way how to become,
you know,
a musician and her producer record.
But I'm saying it started with just kind of being like,
I'm just going to rapper or whatever it was I was going to do,
you know,
and then pick up the guitar was just,
and I'm just going to play this little thing I wrote and maybe if he,
uh,
that's kind of brilliant though in a way because it's so uninfluenced and
influence at the same time,
you know,
instead of being influenced by like classical instruction and you know,
structure and all that stuff,
you're influenced by just what you enjoy and imitating that,
you know,
and then expressing it in your own way.
It's,
you know,
it's amazing.
It's a,
that's very rare that you know that someone's ever done that.
Right.
And that,
you know,
when you meet other people that are musicians,
so they have the same story.
No,
not really.
I mean,
a lot of them really trip on the way I like do what I do,
you know,
especially like when I bring,
because I always bring in cast to help produce records.
I,
I think even though I could probably accomplish the deed on my own,
you need people to challenge you in the course of creating something,
just to make it that much better.
Collaborate and bounce shit back and forth.
Just somebody that you can trust enough that would say,
that sucks.
Even just,
even if it's just somebody that's at your guy,
he's your my guy,
to make sure if something sucks,
you're the voice.
You know what I mean?
Who's,
who's opinion you trust.
Yeah.
And also creatively,
whatever it is,
you know?
I mean,
there's a lot of instruments I can't play,
you know,
that I know cats that can play.
So,
um,
it's just,
you know,
they,
all of them go to school,
all that.
That's what I'm saying.
I steal everything I can from all of them,
you know what I mean?
It's like I'm always the worst musician in the room in my mind because I don't
know what I don't.
I still,
even though I'll get up and play with anybody and it'll work,
I still have this thing in the back of my mind was like,
I don't know what the hell I'm doing.
It's like,
man,
okay.
I'm just kind of sneaking on stage and seeing if I blend.
I'm like the soy bomb guy from the,
from the Grammy's.
Remember that guy who came out here and dealing with the soy bomb written on his
chest?
It was wild.
I'm like,
Geez,
I'm just sneaking onto the set trying to get some,
but you got another.
People must love that.
There's something so authentic about that.
There's something so authentic about just kind of like learn how to play music
by making noises with a guitar until you figured it out.
Pretty fucking watching,
watching the videos real close and right.
Vhs,
pausing them and the things shaken and you're trying to see where his fingers
are on the thing.
We like,
what card is that?
I'm going to try and do that.
Did you breed a book on it or anything and he's not,
you know,
I took a few guitar lessons when like when I was real young,
like maybe six or eight guitar lessons and then kind of lost interest in it.
And then cause hip hop kind of stole my mind away.
And then later on during the house of pain days I,
there's actually a bunch of stuff on house of Payne records that are just little
things that I played that we looped up and put it,
you know,
like little country riff or that shit kicker song ever.
Every time I go to town,
people started kicking my dog around.
There's a guitar piece under the air that I played is,
so there's little bits of it,
but it's like after I left house of pain,
I just started,
I had a guitar around
me all the time and I just started really actually saying,
let me see what I can do with this thing.
And the cat who helped me produce Weide Force sings the blues,
uh,
or I should say produced the record with me,
Dante Ross w we were just working on hip hop music and I was just kind of
crashing his place and playing guitar all the time.
And he'd be like,
what is that?
And it was this thing and I didn't even know what it was.
Yeah,
but that's what it turned out to be.
What it's like,
he was like,
we're going to record that tomorrow.
And I was like,
I don't even know what it is.
So now I'm thinking I got to record this meeting tomorrow.
So I stay up all night and I like write lyrics to it.
And you know,
it turned out we'd put it into a little beat and we were sitting there listening
to it and were like,
that works.
But how does it work with all this stuff?
You're doing this rat record.
And that's how the other songs and Whitey Ford just kind of started happening.
I just,
they just,
like I said,
the music just started surrounding me.
I lit,
I listened to the music more than let's say I have this definite idea of what a
song is.
I'll,
I'll get a lyrical idea or a little riff idea and I'll start working on that.
And then once that takes a little bit of life,
it'll start telling me what it wants.
It will be like,
I want to,
I want out here a slide guitar on it or there should be a piano right there.
I can hear it in the,
in the,
in the space that's in between.
It's telling me I don't like,
I'm not this dude who was like,
I know what parts and what,
but I'll be like,
I know what sounds should go right there cause it's,
I can hear it.
And then you add that sound and it will sub harmonically create this other go
sound in there that you're like,
oh that's a violin.
I can hear it.
Let's put a violin in there.
And it builds itself into what it's supposed to be.
That's amazing.
That's pretty fucking fat ass man.
When I was a kid,
I had friends that were musicians and I was always terrified to learning a
musical instrument.
I was like,
that shit looks like it.
Take it to mine.
I'm still terrified of learning a new musical instrument,
man.
Do you find like,
like technology has helped you a lot?
Like,
er,
you know,
like not garageband bite and they guide programming and the most programs
nowadays,
and I,
I do,
I have to keep an engineer around all the time on,
on,
on duty and ready to go because I'm so I can get on the laptop and go on youtube
and find some stupid videos that'll make me laugh.
You know,
I can get on the Facebook and the Twitter and whatnot,
but I,
you know,
if I could,
I could probably get two tracks recorded at the studio on my own before I just,
you know,
turned in for the day.
That would take me probably about six hours,
which would take him about eight minutes.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
um,
the technology is helped
by making it easier to have your own studio.
You know what I mean?
Instead of spending $1 million on a studio and spend 40 $50,000 and I have a
really beautiful studio.
Know what I mean?
But uh,
Eh,
um,
I'm,
I'm still with just,
it's all about 90% of what I do is,
you know,
either at my studio or late at night in a room by myself with the Acoustic
Guitar Banging on it,
trying to think of something or witty or
will you,
will you really nailed was this kind of like bluesy smooth hip hoppy sound,
you know,
that nobody had ever done before.
Like,
like what it's like,
that's like there's a lot of blues to that song.
You know,
there's just kind of walk the line between Brad from sublime and why clef John
has kind of really like,
was like I saw,
I saw with white cliffs started doing,
you know,
with all his arm being an island influenced music makes him that way.
Hip Hop.
And I was just kind of starting to record this guitar stuff to what it's like
song and I was a big fan of sublime and how he always like injected little these
little hip hop phrases into lyrics and things.
I knew he had to be never really knew the dude,
but knew we had to be kind of a bboy to a certain degree and those kinds of
things.
I,
that's,
that's Kinda how we saw that it would all work when we were,
we were looking at the record and me and my friend Dante,
my label thought Whitey Ford sings the blues was a horrible idea.
You're like,
it always works.
Yeah.
It was because we were convinced what we know this is gonna work.
This is like,
there's no,
you know,
it's just what it is,
you know?
It's all the same thing to me.
I'm a,
that's what I always say is like,
I consider myself a hip hop artists,
but I also don't really believe in any genre of music.
I just think music's music.
You know what I mean?
Tony Bennett has some stuff that makes me go like this.
Right.
And I'll be like,
oh that's hip hop to me.
Cause that's the same thing.
Hip Hop made me the reins,
Zeppelin song,
somebody else that's rock and roll with somebody who has caused that jazz.
It's somebody,
you know what I mean?
But it's whatever makes you personally.
Yeah.
Ooh.
What does that kind of feeling?
Yeah,
I like a lot of country music and some,
some people give me shit about that.
I like some Toby Keith songs.
Man,
not so big on new country cause I'm just not hip to the game.
But I love country music.
When you're going to,
you're going to like that record shop.
I love it.
I'm a fan of yours and you drive home tonight,
you popped that record and you took,
by the time you get home and find him see like a text from me.
Like that's a bad ass.
Right?
It goes great with whiskey.
I,
I feel,
I bet.
I believe it will.
But I know Anthony Martinez again country,
but there's definitely country friendly man.
Yeah,
well it's got a,
a slang to it,
you know,
it's kind of smoothness to it.
I know.
It's a,
it's a,
it's great shit man.
I love it.
I'm a,
I'm a huge fan of shit.
And one of the things that Anthony Bordain said we were having this conversation
once,
you know,
he didn't become famous till he's like in his forties.
Oh,
hold up,
let me pick up their name.
You just dropped your man.
No,
no,
it's good because I'm going to say it because it for you.
Um,
but he said,
well,
the coolest thing about becoming famous is that you get to meet famous people.
Like that is the coolest day.
Absolutely.
And meeting you and hanging out with you at the UFC.
Look,
one time we were,
we were smoking a joint in a Vegas Casino.
We're in,
in the middle of a bar and a,
I go,
are you go,
you wanna smoke a joint?
I go,
yeah,
where are we?
Where are you going to go?
And he goes,
Everlast just goes,
me,
me and go.
Yeah.
I was like,
where you go satellite or pulls out a lot.
I'm like,
oh,
all right,
well fuck it man.
If I got arrested,
at least I'm getting arrested with Everlast the worst day and ask us to put it
out,
man,
you don't have to worst.
We'd be like,
Hey,
come on man.
They give you that look like,
dude,
don't make my job harder.
You can still smoke in a nightclub in Vegas,
Huh?
Cigarettes allowed in nightclubs in Vegas.
I don't know but we've smoked in a nightclub before.
Remember we just stepped out that door and
door.
That's outside.
But is there an inside area?
Are you allowed to smoke inside anywhere in the morning now it's not.
I try to remember last time I still do it in the casino
cause I still see people smoking in the casinos pulling that out though.
They're slowly pulling the cigarettes will fight that tooth and nail at all.
I guess it's the real problem is that people that work there and I get it man,
if you're a waitress,
why the fuck you should?
You have to breathe that shit in all day.
I smoked a cigarette and a long time.
That's a tricky drug.
Still.
Think about it.
Nah.
See,
cause what happened to me was I woke up in the hospital that had emergency heart
surgery like 98.
So it was like,
I was like,
Oh,
I'm done smoking.
Wow.
I didn't even,
I mean like I still smoke some weed now and then,
but like,
you know,
even for like three years,
two years after that,
about two years after the surgery,
I didn't,
I was like,
awesome.
Hell No,
I'm,
I'm alive.
I'm trying to what?
I can never sleep because I,
um,
I what happened was I went to bed Stuy.
I'm real tired.
I'm not feeling good.
Went to sleep and woke up in cedars like after surgery.
So like in my mind was on this like,
don't go sleep.
Kind of like trip.
Oh,
like a long time.
I was like an insomniac man.
Oh Man.
But I would let my band guys smoke a little weed up in the front of the bus and
one night I decided was I couldn't sleep as usual,
but that somebody has something real.
Just,
I like reminisce.
I was like,
wow.
Now.
That's some,
that's something quality up there.
So I went out to just kind of smelly and I was like,
you know what,
let me just,
and everybody was like,
are you sure?
I was like,
I'm a grown man.
Let me it like that dad.
So all I did,
I gave it back to them that I went to the back of the bus.
I slept like a God damn baby man.
So it became for like a good long time,
few years I that's,
that's all it was right before bed.
Sleep like a baby.
A lot of people use it for that.
I know a lot of people that are in Sunday and of course you know we wanted them
started young and after a while you lose,
you lose that humbleness that almost dying gives you and you're out at the club.
And so he was like,
I have to join.
I hit the joint before I go to bed.
I'll hit it now.
But now and they say,
no,
you're smoking.
It's lucky you had somebody next to you though because you just went to sleep.
What if you didn't have somebody next to you it
than that?
Like during the day,
like the guys that were making the record where me,
we had the studio in my house,
I had a house up in Mount Olympus in Laurel Canyon and we were just,
I just built a studio up in there to record the record and everybody was living
in the house and apparently just all day I wasn't feeling,
I don't,
I just didn't feel well and I didn't look well.
And when I went to lay down,
I guess somebody came and checked on me just to be like,
hey,
you all right.
And I guess I was breathing funny and they just panicked,
called hot.
Like coach shook me a few times.
I guess I wouldn't wake up,
call the hospital,
you know,
it was my extreme fortune to live in a neighborhood,
uh,
that the,
the,
the closest hospital was Cedar Sinai.
Oh,
nice.
And then it was,
it was,
you know,
also my,
uh,
Irish luck that,
the best heart surgeon in the world who Dr. William Trento was,
who's chief of heart surgery over there.
I think of maybe even of all surgery,
saw my case and told somebody else that you can't do that.
I have to do that my life.
This is what happened to me is the same.
He killed John Ritter in like 30 minutes.
Jesus Christ,
the same exact thing.
What is it exactly?
I believe if I remember correctly,
it was called an upper ascending aortic aneurism and what I have in there now as
a saint Jude's heart valve,
it's a titanium heart valve.
Like I tick like a watch man woe and you want to hear,
hold on,
get real sensitive on this mark right here.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Yeah,
like 14 years now.
That's like white noise to me.
I,
I could take my pulse without anything.
I could just,
okay.
Take my whole
career about titanium valve in your heart.
Yeah.
Wow.
Is it Bluetooth enabled
dude kill like a robot.
The bionic bionic rapper man.
For Real.
That is kind of crazy,
man.
Isn't it amazing they can do shit like that,
right?
Yeah.
And you've had it in your body for how many years in [inaudible] 98 since nine
February 98
that's amazing.
Freaking me out,
man.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
I don't know how to react to that.
It's amazing.
Alien Technology,
man.
That's why I love while watching your Twitter dude,
cause they'll always be some crazy tweet like some fan or tweet you like Yo
aliens dropped off the cure for cancer ed.
You know the whatever it is.
Fort Knox.
Yeah,
it's flying over some of the hospital right now.
Yeah.
I'll be like,
Oh man,
I love that.
Cause I know I got an alien technology and my body man,
it's titanium that's got a titanium heart valves and saying how does that work?
Wow,
that's amazing.
I mean imagine trying to explain that to someone.
200 years ago they were going to cut this dude open and we're going to stick
some shit inside there where his shit's broken.
It's going to be made out of a metal craft.
You're just a weird metal.
Yeah.
Why wouldn't even bother trying to comprehend this man,
this man,
the way it's burning him,
all the bacteria off of him.
How are you going to do that?
I,
that's what the bacteria is there to test the weakness.
You know,
you get cut open like that.
It's supposed to attack.
That's nature.
Like some subverting the entire system sticking titanium inside of PE,
but it's amazing.
It's incredible.
I have to take a blood thinner for the rest of my life,
so a clap doesn't form around it and break off and going into my brain.
What is the flow?
Huh?
What's a blood thinner?
How's that work?
It's an anticoagulant.
Just so just a pill that you take that you know and I have to like,
does it make you like bleed more if you get cut?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
You're quite as fast.
Wow.
I should give up
riding my motorcycle and a few other entities of that nature because if you get
cut you just start bleeding out.
Yeah.
If it was severe enough.
Cut.
Yeah.
Wow.
Who Shit that's in.
Isn't it amazing how the human body can just just be fragile at some points and
just you have to just deal with some issues.
But when you do,
there's a,
there's a certain humility and a certain like respect for life when you've
gotten through some bad shit,
you know,
do you feel that
the way I tried to explain it to people is like most people,
unless you're really highly intelligent and enlightened,
which is not what I'm saying I am when I'm about to say what I'm about to say,
I'm just saying some cats just reached death at this point where they're just
ready for it and they,
and they're,
and they're ready to cope.
You know what I mean?
But most of us probably see death,
you know,
coming at us and you know,
there's,
I look at it like a roller coaster.
Like,
you know,
going on this roller coaster,
you told us the scariest roller coaster of all time and you're waiting to go on
it and probably the whole time you're waiting to go on that motherfucker,
it's probably really scary.
Then you get on it and you're riding once and it's probably really scary,
but then you know,
if you,
if you get off it and get right back in line,
you know,
the waiting line isn't so scary and then you get back on the ride again.
It's like I,
that's what I compared that to.
It's like I've gone through all the terror,
kind of terrifying parts of death thinking I was,
it was upon me.
I was,
I was like,
you know,
woke up in the hospital like I did what?
To me,
there's this like,
I got this scar on my chest.
I'm thinking,
you know,
it's so rap.
You know what I mean?
I,
I vaguely remember like,
people talk about a flash of your life flashing before your eyes,
but it,
to me it was more of just the sum,
the sum realization of,
wow,
man,
that whole 28 years was that long.
That's,
that's Kinda what it was for me.
It wasn't like all these moments.
It was just like the summit,
the,
the uh,
the realize the realization that my life was like a second long in the scheme of
things.
Wow.
And uh,
so it's intense.
It's about as intense as it gets.
Right.
You know,
it's,
it's crazy.
Surgery is about as intense as it gets,
but I figure like this the next time death upon me,
all the scary parts or con I've been on this roller coaster.
What,
what comes after that?
It's,
it really is a trip that it's facing everyone,
but no one wants to bring it up.
It's,
it's,
it's really the subject.
I can't testify either to any lights at the end,
any tunnels.
But like,
I do also remember hearing a v like what I,
the only way I can describe it as hearing a very familiar voice.
Like I never really knew any of my grandfather's,
but it seemed like a grandfather's type voice.
Just kind of,
you know,
it ain't,
you ain't ready yet.
It's not your time.
But I didn't,
I didn't go along with like a light or a vision or a figure.
It was just,
I was,
I don't remember,
is other than this realization about how short my life was and my life could
have been 90 years and that,
that realization would have been exactly the same.
You know what I mean?
But then there's this kind of blackness and his voice being like,
Nah,
no,
you ain't get anytime or something of that nature.
Like that's the,
I can't even say it was words as much as just something communicating that
feeling to me
it's a real trip to think the idea that this is,
there is a time for you and there is a place for you and there's a thing that
you should be doing.
A lot of people want to think that that's grandiose to think like that.
Oh,
you silly.
You know,
you're like,
cause it's been like,
you know,
the deep,
this parts of my subconscious like fighting for their lives,
trying to convince me there's a reason to be a lot.
You know,
there's that part,
there's that part.
I mean there's,
uh,
I've battled it ever since.
Was it was,
it was.
Was where those spiritual thoughts or where was it scientific and your mind
fighting to stay alive.
Right.
You know what I mean?
The Ego.
Plenty of stuff,
man.
I don't get no chamber but I get in my pool often late at night with the lights
off and just lay there with it over my ears in silence for a couple hours
you would dig an isolation tank.
You would take the shit out of it,
man.
For you it'd be beautiful because it's a non drug drug.
He could just go in there and be healthy and great for your body and it's very
relaxing.
Oh my God,
I bet it's things like bad,
that tank that might be,
you might have the trippiest dreams in there ever because well you know what it
is.
You know how it works.
You've never done it before and I've never actually done it.
Man.
You should own one and you should be in it daily.
It's a beautiful thing is going to set me back proper 7,000 for a real good one.
That'll last forever.
It's got a big thick lining like the the,
the,
the kind of used to make Koi ponds.
It's all heated.
The water,
it's beautiful.
It's,
it's super reliable.
It never leaked.
You just turn it on when you want to get in there,
boom.
Opened the door hop band and after you get out of the turn,
you turn on the pump.
It's like the most low maintenance thing and man,
it's what a,
what an environment that is proud is often you do it all the time.
I mean every day as much as I can.
Sometimes I don't like to do it every day because then reality gets a little
slippery.
Isn't that right?
Yeah.
I spent too much time alone with the tank.
I just find myself getting really weird dates going on.
I find myself going to friends with my thoughts.
I get,
I get so far deep that it's very difficult to go to the supermarket.
Do you not get pruney when you get in,
you don't come out looking like Mr. Burns or side notes.
I think maybe the saltwater keeps that from happening.
You know the water's really salted is 800 pounds of salt in it,
so it's a different thing when you come out and you don't,
you're not all pruned up.
I don't know have be funny if you're,
even if you're worried just that's why you failed to always mentioned that every
time you get out and he just looked like a five year old kid dying.
It's one of those things.
Whenever I get out of there I'm like,
this is amazing that no one knows about this.
They should be,
they should teach this in school.
They should have people in high school getting an tanks and have people talking
to them and coach them through life.
You shouldn't help everybody.
Joe Rogan,
isolation tank.
Too much work.
I don't have time for that a pop man.
It sounds like there's that much profit.
To be honest with you,
it's,
it's a lot of it is steel components.
You have to get it manufactured and built.
There's this super fucking Jacuzzi system.
What's his incredible filtration system and make sure that no microbes can get
in there and fuck with your skin.
And then on top of that,
you have to make sure the water stays exactly the same temperature.
It's a lot of technology into it.
You know how you could do it is you have to get it like a $200 on Amazon,
like affordable system that you make out of like a box.
Oh Dude,
you wouldn't want that.
What does it fucking broke in your living room?
Fucked up your whole house then I'd be responsible.
No,
you don't want that man.
George Foreman of a isolation tank.
So that's the thing about a tank man.
If you're going to get one,
you gotta,
you know it's gotta be built correctly.
Someone's got to go in there and do it.
They have a build it yourself one.
It seems to me too much room for error,
but you know,
people would buy it works pretty good late at night with the lights off,
man.
You know,
I'm a floating the floating right.
I'm boy yet.
Oh,
you just,
you can float on your back in the pool.
Holy Shit.
That's amazing.
That's incredible.
I sink like a rock.
I can't do that,
but if you get in that water tank,
the isolation tank,
then it's beautiful.
Imagine the other thing is that the temperature is perfect.
It's the exact temperature is your skin so that when you're in there,
you fail to be able to,
after a while you don't differentiate,
which isn't the exact temperature of p yeah,
probably
comes out of your body.
Right.
It must be just need a garbage bag and just piss yourself sitting inside of it.
Yeah.
I try not to pee in the tank,
but you know sometimes shit happens.
Nasty.
Yeah.
You don't want to smell that while you're in there trying to achieve
enlightenment,
smelling your own piss going,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
Sitting there,
sitting there pressing on myself and an isolation.
Have you ever seen somebody that had a pool that was so bad ass,
like they had a lazy river around it?
Can you imagine how bad has,
would that be if you just had a lazy river?
I'm like a huge pool.
Yeah.
I knew this dude who had a,
he had this giant pool and he had some crazy fucking slide system built into it,
like water slides and everything built into the side of his hill,
just like a floating,
Dang.
We're just goes around and around.
So you just sit and they're like a little raft and just go in and circle a
Disneyland ride.
Like those pools are where they had like a little lazy river around the whole
entire cool.
That would be okay,
but I'm telling you the isolation tanks better.
I want to meet somebody so flows a moat.
The moat,
the next level that's like of Croatia.
Shit you live in Glendale with.
I know there's no,
Princeton's is in Croatia.
Don't,
don't get angry at me.
Croatian people.
I love you guys.
Yeah,
man.
That's some next level shit.
Right?
That's what after the next Zombie Apocalypse,
after 2012 people are going to start making moats.
I'm moving out to city.
I'm going to have a moat.
Where are you going to try to make this compound?
And when you're thinking northern California is a good move.
Northern cal could climate.
Yeah.
Not Too.
Not Too hot.
Not too cold or too rainy.
Gets you a little,
you get a little weather which keeps you honest.
I like the weapons.
The vegan people.
Well the weather's good for people.
I think people are delusional in California because they never get hit by
whether they're like they just like have no,
they have no respect for what nature can do to Garmin.
Yeah.
It never hits here.
You know when you get here you get a little bit of rain.
Do you do,
it's like every now and then it rains.
Like people here really have no idea what the fuck whether is like,
yeah,
but we get earthquakes.
Rarely man.
Rarely you're going to have,
they're definitely coming.
We're all going to and we're all going to be like,
why didn't we paid?
The Tab
is indeed,
but I think earthquakes by and large,
you know,
you don't get trapped under a giant building.
The crushes your head.
By and large.
See,
I'm thinking San Diego be close to the biggest air force base ever.
You know,
that just seems like it would make sense.
San Diego be close to the base will be the most protected other than being in
Los Angeles where everyone's going to fucking die.
Does that what you think?
Why,
but why do you think that earthquakes won't hit like a turf wars earthquakes?
No,
no,
no strikes out or a Zombie apocalypse or when the Martians come,
we'll actually talk about this.
I'm worried about this shit,
dude.
We're worried about the fall of civilizations.
Andy boy listens to like Alex Jones,
all that stuff.
Like he's got that iHeart radio APP and he's always watching,
listening to that late night over right.
Stuffed all the craziness.
And I was like this,
he was listening to a show that was actually about Zombie apocalypse and zombies
and people discussing them.
And I was like,
this is real.
People talking about this.
That's crazy is ridiculous.
But could you imagine if it was possible to make a Zombie?
You know,
it could be it,
it would probably just be a virus of some kind.
Now we're talking about,
well it sounds stupid,
but there's this way,
crazier parasites that exist in the world.
You know,
every single human being is essentially a symbiotic.
Every person has a conglomeration of all sorts of different organisms living
inside their body.
And without those,
you can't even be alive.
It's,
and when you get a parasite,
like when a parasite fucks up a body,
what that is,
is a failed symbiotic.
It's like it's trying to have a symbiotic relationship with the organism,
but it's failing.
So it's sucking out too many resources so becomes a parasite.
It's not contributing to the overall system.
Understood.
It is possible that they could come up with something that would hijack your
shit so bad that you would be like one of those 28 days later,
motherfucker.
That is so 100% absolutely.
Speaking of the dead rise,
oh no,
no.
We're talking about lanes.
28 days later is a Zombie movie.
Apocalypse so long enough to figure this out.
And I just like these things about zombies right now,
dude,
I'm telling you.
Realistic Zombie rules totally geeking out on Zombie rules.
The 28 days later was not a Zombie movie in the same thing.
It was a disease or that was created.
It was like,
what was it called,
rage or something like that and they gave it to champion and chimps got out and
fucked up a whole
city with it.
Totally.
That's totally possible.
It is totally possible.
There's a worm that lives inside a grasshopper.
It's an aquatic worm and it grows in its body and then when it gets to the age
where it's about to hatch,
it talks the grasshopper into drowning itself.
It controls the grasshoppers body,
hops the grass over over to some water,
leaps into it.
So then he called pop out some aquatic worm,
some aquatic worms.
It's an actual grantee.
Google aquatic worm.
Grasshopper parasite.
Yeah,
Harris parasite.
None.
Amazing.
Tricks it into drowning itself.
That's amazing.
They can pop out of its little body if that's possible.
Anything's possible.
I know that's a lower organism.
They've already extracted it and there's a pill.
Yeah.
And the guy talking to you,
it was already infected by,
hey,
we all might be,
that's what I said about clones.
Found it on Google.
You found the gold,
the grasshopper thing.
Brainwashed by parasitic worms and that amazing.
Yeah,
that baby.
Where is that?
Cause I want to go there and just find some drown.
That's like a fun camping trip.
Well,
they're finding now more and more of these parasitic relationships that worms
have.
Dude.
I mean to people.
Millions of organisms are living on us as we speak.
There's all,
there's a lot on yours right there.
This one are mine.
I'm sure the little bugs that are actually probably helping out,
keeping it clean and shit.
Yeah,
exactly right.
I mean that's what rubbing butts with the whole deal of Acidophilus is.
Right.
You know.
I won't lie though,
man.
It brings them in my mind.
That brings me straight to bed bugs.
Like how that whole outbreak in the east coast,
I was like not wanting to go to that.
I was like,
man,
I ain't trying to bring bedbugs home.
I know.
Can imagine that they get in your clothes and shit,
you're fucked.
It's just multiplying your house.
Oh,
and you've got to get a diffused.
It's easy to believe all that.
How quickly,
you know,
it was like people trip on know the nuclear,
this nuclear,
they're not and it's going to be a little germ.
Nate gets all of us,
man.
It can be easily.
It could be.
There's been threats of it for,
you know,
who knows how long.
I mean every time.
One of the things that hits everybody,
like when the swine flu came out of the bird flu or anything that comes out,
it's like this might be the one we're all scared of because we all know that
it's possible.
That one super bug that comes along with,
well,
they got us convinced that at at at least,
and you use every opportunity they can come,
right.
Whatever new vaccine they got out.
I sadly like,
how are we going to sterilize these folks for off?
Yeah.
What the fuck is a lot of vaccine drills aren't working fast enough.
Are you a believer in chem trails?
I passed them,
right.
It's not pat.
No.
That's how I look at it all.
I mean,
like I look at it like the cats who like,
you know,
if you won't even take the nine 11,
there's cats to be like,
there's no way we did this.
I was like,
well,
there's proof that the very least we knew something was supposed to happen.
Just like that hijacked airplanes.
There was reports that they were going to try and do this and nothing was done
the extra to stop it.
That's kind of a passive participation at the very least.
So I don't see past anything.
I,
all the heart and all this,
I love it.
I love reading about it and learning about it and giving it just enough
consideration to be like,
it could be true.
I'm not being,
I'm not living by it,
but I'm watching it and be like,
okay,
if,
uh,
some crazy scenario breaks out in the world where people just can't breathe
anymore,
there might be something to these stories.
Yeah.
You would have to think of why would they be doing it?
There's gotta be a prophet to it.
You've got to talk somebody and doing it.
I think for sure there have been some chem trail experiments.
I don't think that's doubted at all.
I think people are well aware of,
there's been some shit,
but the real question is like how much are they doing on a regular basis?
I don't think it's like how think they're spraying cities.
This is what I call a lot of places and see him everywhere.
Do you think this brand,
people do think they try to control the population?
When I was young,
that was just a jet going by ray smoked it and stick around all day.
One of my favorite videos on
for a ridiculousness is prince sitting down with Dick Gregory and he's talking
about how I think it's Dick Gregory.
He's talking about how um,
there's um,
a chem trails and they fly over the hood and then all of sudden everybody starts
fighting and he goes,
and I saw these planes fly over and I was thinking,
why is everybody fighting?
And they're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You're,
you're in the hood.
Like what do you expect?
Do you think that the planes flying overhead is there spraying,
fighting juice down on the people,
not the poverty.
It's not the poverty or the rage or the criminal element.
That's what the drug throughout your community?
Yeah.
Or all sorts of corrupt shit that's going on right now.
It's,
this is a plane,
the spraying some shit down and all of a sudden everybody's getting upset.
That's ridiculous.
It's a hilarious video.
I think we need to look into those green boxes that used to have in your
backyard that,
that hummed pepper really warm.
Cause I used to like as a kid lay on those things for probably years.
You know,
and just,
I don't even know what you're talking.
Well in the Midwest or I guess in the suburbs,
not in Los Angeles.
I,
they used to have these green boxes that were like energy plants or something
like that.
I don't know what they were.
They're just like these and they hum do an eight and there were super warm.
And I remember just sitting out there as a kid for hours,
like on it.
Like I was recharging and I've probably got,
I don't know,
databank bites or something.
I don't know what it's just,
what is that thing?
So many things when you were little that could have made you,
I know.
What is that thing going on?
I think everyone did that.
I don't know what you're talking about for awhile.
I'll show you a picture of one.
Familiar yeah.
And the energy source.
It like a weird bond.
Some tasks community,
their own nuclear power plants in their backyard.
Yeah.
Columbus,
Ohio cancer cluster,
nuclear reactors.
There was a test market town.
So like we had like,
like you know banana frosties before everyone you were a test market town?
Yes.
Columbus,
Ohio.
Who would tell they would test us out like burgers and like I would talk to my
friends,
my cousins that live in a different state and they're like,
we don't have that kind of a weird burger at Mcdonald's.
What are you talking about?
And found out that the people that companies test market Columbus,
Ohio cause that's the most average city in the whole entire country.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Columbus is like that.
You know,
like the whitest people,
I don't know.
Almost pretty close to the middle too,
isn't it?
Columbus?
Sure.
Yeah.
Do you ever hear of about sister's chicken?
Did you guys ever have that was a Wendy's version of KFC that they were trying
out.
Uh,
and it was just three old ladies was the logo and there was like KFC,
like wicked sisters and,
and uh,
I don't think it work though,
like last,
like two years or something.
Never heard of it.
Yeah.
That's a good idea.
I'll show you the green box.
Set
the green box.
The green box fucked you up.
Another thing that happened to him,
he was living in an apartment and there's a duct overhead,
like a heating duct where the hot air would come through.
It turns out that wasn't what that was.
Somebody had hooked up the wrong thing to the gas furnace and it was blowing
straight carbon dioxide from the gas furnace.
No.
Yes.
Yeah.
He lived like that for a year.
Okay.
Here's the do not blow up.
He's dead.
And how exactly that on the inside a long time ago.
Uh,
here's,
here's the green box and it makes them stutter.
Now.
Green bars,
similar things,
but like on the corners of intersection.
Yeah.
We had one in our backyard and I would just sit there and get data bytes pumped
into me as a child.
Obviously it has something to do with electricity,
but it's something to do with electricity.
Yeah.
That's not good.
But we didn't have the warning labels.
Like this one has a nice warning label,
don't like something on it.
Like,
Hey,
don't even get close to this,
this,
have they ever made it
connection or correlation between um,
live in near power?
Like those big giant towers,
you know,
those,
uh,
electrical towers,
right?
The cancer clusters that they have made a correlation?
Well,
no,
it's,
it's one of them things where you can find both sides that will have equally
compelling arguments that right there.
Right.
So that means no,
there has been no definitive,
but I mean it's,
don't let it write down to kind of common sense a little bit.
If you're camped under these things that are like
scared.
Were you just thinking about that with power lines?
I mean
there's so much fucking power going through their house.
You notice though most public parks or right under it.
Under those.
Yeah.
That's the only free spot that was available.
That's cheap land.
There it is.
That's where we're putting the school.
Yeah man.
When you drive by those things and you can hear them,
you're roll down your window and the heavy duty ones,
you know what I mean?
A big iron towers were terrified tables.
I did.
I saw a show about that once man with the guys are on helicopters,
they have to do the maintenance for those lines.
They actually have to make a connection to the line like with the helicopter to
ground it before they could start working with their parents of the most
dangerous jobs you can have.
That might've been the show I was watching like life's most dangerous jobs.
Those dudes are nuts.
The fuck they're like in metal.
Just think of what that must be.
You must be feeling when you're above one of those things and you know that just
touching it,
just reaching out and touching.
You just would essentially below they're grabbing it.
I like
the connectors that keep working together.
They're fake.
They're fixing it.
You have to trust it.
We gotta know the in the sign,
another piece of the helicopter that they have to call and it has to touch the
wire while they're working on it.
Apparently one of the most common things is it isn't getting electrocuted.
It's that the tail of the helicopter hits the wire and they just go,
oh my God,
the oblivion.
Oh,
of course.
If they get hit with a gust,
right.
It's almost impossible for them to stop.
It's apparently like one of the craziest,
most dangerous jobs.
If you did,
if you had to do that.
I was watching that.
I was just so nice.
I think I was on the bag and it's all glass,
just like 18 hour drive just watching whenever it was on,
but I was a deck stumbled across that.
I was like,
Oh,
here,
here's,
here's the helicopter thing right here.
Actually that's you singing.
What are you doing?
I got on the helicopter.
What's wrong with you?
It's
is it?
Yeah.
This might've been the show.
Yeah,
that was me before getting on it.
Watch this dog.
These nuts,
man.
They're like these crazy suits.
One guy's got to touch the wire.
You know what I'm saying?
Like God,
this is
Zane.
Oh my God.
He has to climb up.
He climbs up and he's sitting in a harness on top of the fucking wires.
Brian,
why did you mix this together?
Brian made this video himself.
Yeah.
This is an old music video.
I didn't mixed with that stuff in it.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Well look at that guy walking on those wires.
That is absolutely horrifying.
That's crazy man.
And I got off garden,
Brent Stafford there volts is know what that is.
Is that what it is?
How much will kill you?
It's a lot less than a lot less now.
That's like they would incinerate you right when you just explode or something.
Yeah,
but he's grounded.
So how like he's like grounded on like,
I watched the whole thing.
Hi Man.
It was,
it was amazing.
And they were charged,
like those dudes were on their own.
Some like adrenaline junkie shit.
Oh,
they must be like just the greatest job.
What could you imagine if it was
doing something to them?
What if it was like making them super power?
They started like
when the x men thinks starts
the,
the whole,
uh,
it might've been me.
What's that really know that had an Ebu Brian,
wasn't it?
And it was pretty loose.
So loud.
No,
I'll tell you right now,
it wasn't me.
It's not me.
All right,
well I'm just glad I'm not the guy who did it.
Yeah.
Anyway,
where were we?
We were talking about how mutations to start.
There's where the x men begin is on them lines,
right?
Yeah.
Is Right
there when,
uh,
one time I,
you know,
when I used to do a fear factor,
I was,
uh,
I would eat like pop candies or something before the show,
just to kind of keep me like,
hey,
chill,
but happy and fun mood day.
Sometimes you sit around all day and it's boring and if you're not,
you know,
kind of buzz,
it doesn't feel as good sometimes.
Sounds interesting.
But one of the days I showed up,
every now and then when something would freak me out,
I would show up at work and I'd be a little banked and they'd tell me what we're
going to do and one of the things they tell them is we're going to have these
people ride bulls.
And I was like,
oh this is a terrible,
terrible,
terrible idea.
Like when you're high and they're telling you you got to ride a bull,
you're like,
oh no sir.
No,
no I'm not getting on that thing.
What is this?
We're going to do what you're going to make people do that.
You're going to get them on and get on there.
I know.
It's fucking crazy.
The only time when we ever did that show where I felt like we were totally
rolling the dice,
hoping nobody got hurt.
That was the only time it was.
We made them ride bowls cause like you can't,
you can't protect them from that fucking animal.
You can only,
you know,
you can only say so much.
We're gonna try.
We're gonna try to keep it from stomping you,
but we can't guarantee you.
We'll give you a chance plate and a helmet,
but you gotta let it.
Imagine you letting the bowl for you with a chest plate and helmet go,
come get me.
I got a chest plate and helmet on.
Oh my God.
You'd feel so fragile.
We got lucky with that one.
One girl,
she was 98 pounds something.
Maybe she was on this ball and she agreed to do it.
I'm like,
you're sure?
She goes,
yeah,
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to go for it.
She got on the fucking boats.
She,
she lasted for just a couple of seconds.
Of course.
Right?
The bull launches her through the air.
She goes flying and just barely misses her with a kick.
Just barely misses her.
And I just would think about like what we're dataless thing.
We could've got this little girl kicked in the head for some stupid reality
show.
You know how much Bray was it at the end of the 50 grand.
If you want.
Right before she falls down.
She was okay.
Funny though,
Dude.
Like not to be little money,
but yeah.
Isn't it funny when people will do for so little money?
Well they do it for fun too.
A lot of them they do it just,
you know,
there's people that do it and they think that they're going to be able to
eventually get some sort of a career in,
in reality.
More funny to me.
Well you know people have done it even though it's actually turned into that and
know it is weird.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like as long as they're nice people,
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
I,
you could start weird out about what people watch and don't watch.
And I have,
I've gone down that road before.
Look at the fuck is wrong with us.
Why are we watching the Kardashians?
But you know,
the other part of me is like,
who gives a fuck?
Hoping she's gonna suck another gig.
So she's done man.
The only way she would suck another deck and say she would have to like drop
drastically in the ratings to make another sex tape.
It would be really hard to get her to put one out.
Now it's like a Nascar race that's not waiting for the end.
They're waiting for the crash.
You know,
here's my prediction.
The next sex tape won't be her getting fucked.
It'd be a duty and their pussy for like a half an hour.
That's it.
That's a sex tape.
And then she releases that one woopsies that got out and that would,
that would kick her back up to the next level if she was like crying at a press
conference.
I can't believe this.
This was so personal.
I use that image to masturbate too when I'm on the road.
My,
my assistant stole it from my laptop,
you know,
that would,
that could be her next level shit.
She might have to do that in about two years.
Cause like now people are like making like Kardashians jokes are probably like
the number one joke on Twitter.
You know,
if you're going make a joke about the Kardashians.
Yeah,
I mean it's like,
it's so low hanging fruit.
It's so easy.
Yeah.
I saw that movie,
young adult last night,
the patent Oswald throughout the whole movie.
There's a,
you know what it's about now.
I Charlise boron and Patton Oswald and it's fucking really funny and really
brilliant,
like a brilliant movie.
But one of the things is the chick who's the crazy chick Charlise neuron,
all she watches is Kim Kardashians.
She just watches it every time you seen her at home.
She's just like sitting in front of the TV watching Kim Kardashian and her
sister talk with like this mindless glaze in her.
I had some scenario.
They go,
holy fuck.
That is America man.
You know those people are responsible for that fucking signal that they're
putting out there,
man.
They are.
They're turning.
If anybody's turning people into zombies.
Yeah,
but this,
this whole movie throughout the whole movie.
That's crazy bitch.
Charlie's thrawn is obsessed with her high school boyfriend.
I was just watching the Kardashians on TV.
It's a good movie,
man.
It's a really,
like,
the ending is kind of weird.
Is it like in the movie theaters movie or just yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I saw it last night.
It's a good movie.
It's fucking Patton.
Oswalt's a bad motherfucker.
He's funny man.
He's going to do the podcast again soon.
Has even done it.
No,
that's it again.
So yeah.
Oops.
Do it soon.
We need to get him on it.
Yeah,
that damn movie.
Then he did it with what Galifianakis and the guy with the glasses.
The comedians of comedy.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Those dudes buddy film that.
Yeah,
that whole thing,
man.
It was hilarious,
Yeah,
those guys are awesome.
There's a,
there's a bunch of real good stand ups right now.
It's a good time for standup comedy.
This is all starting to break through to like in other forms like,
you know,
like you know,
of course Zack.
Yeah.
Patton Oswald everywhere.
Holy Zach Galifianakis is one of those guys that I can help smile when I'm
watching him.
Yeah.
He's like one of those guys.
I see him doing something stupid in the movie of,
you know,
even then,
what was it due date or something like that.
Wasn't the best movie in the world,
but I'm watching him and he,
he's,
he makes me smile.
It's just so ridiculous.
You know,
Brody stole the whole movie,
Do you think so?
I loved the little Brody hiding like out of nowhere you will find our friend
Brody Stevens,
I,
he's friends with Zach.
So every time Zach as a movie or does anything,
Zach throws him in as like these little rolls and stuff and every role it's
almost playing like a where's Waldo for Brody Stevens.
Like oh there he is.
He's in the,
he's a police
guy.
Whoops.
Why did you have a Google?
I forgot to switch it back to my camera.
You start tripping me the fuck out.
I'm like what?
What's your point when now?
Cause the whole thing is starting to trip me out of the car is over here.
It's very distracted TV over here where my face,
like I'll turn in,
my face will be on it.
It'll start on me and then I'll look back and it'll be like some other thing and
some goats.
Yeah.
This is a,
the next level of add type shit for people.
Just,
you know,
just a conversation alone.
It's just,
it's too boring,
man.
It's like 18 screens going,
dude.
He was showing me earlier,
he was just watching random strangers play video
games.
He does that.
He'll go and watch watch video games essentially would be the home page.
And it was like,
I was like,
that's the fucking matrix.
Look at it dude.
Like what game do you want to what?
Spy On women's tennis.
All those people are in the fucking computer,
right?
They're all playing games.
Most of them are trying to kill each other.
Exactly.
The nuts and you know,
this is only step one.
What's it going to look like a hundred years from now?
It's going to be a drone warfare dude is just,
what was your go to video game back in the day when you played a lot of games?
The last one I was uh,
I was kind of a socom freak.
So I like seeing the guy like the character,
I don't like the word you.
All you see is the hands and the gun.
I liked seeing the little guy running around.
I don't want to feel like I'm actually killing people.
I know there's a game going.
Right.
Have you played gears of war that's kind of like that?
I think one of the first versions I might played,
I,
you know,
when I got married and had a kid,
man,
it was just,
it was a rap,
like the video games,
like video games.
It's hard and the video games to me is I've,
I said I just,
I'm always terrified that I'm going to come addicted to them.
I'm terrified.
They're too good man.
Video Games these days.
By the time I'm an old man and retire,
I could just sit around and did.
It shouldn't be crazy by then and be like three dimensional surround sound.
You're going to pierce your own brand.
You got to pierce your own temple with somebody else that's going to,
she's at,
what was that crazy Christopher Walken movie with the brain stuff with Natalie
Wood.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
is that moving?
Yeah.
Dreams.
Dreams something dreamscape.
Jared is,
yeah.
Wow.
Did you know that?
There's a new questions about Natalie Wood and her husband.
Yeah.
A few month or so ago.
Yeah,
man.
Just,
just recently.
Robert Wagner.
Wagner man.
Well,
that's what this guy's saying this,
right?
Oh yeah,
but they saw him on the the,
on today's show.
I think he was on,
it was also selling a book,
you know?
Yeah.
He was selling a book on what she said that Robert Wagner killed her.
He said he heard a bunch of fighting.
They heard like violence and then he heard silence.
What's that guy's name again?
Do you know that?
The guy that the guy was right in the book?
Robert Wagner.
Robert Wagner?
Yeah.
Robert Wagner.
Natalie,
I got to find you this.
I got to find you.
This video.
It's going to trip you out.
This guy asks this question to the guy that's selling the book.
He asked the same question like seven times in a row and it got to the point
where it was like a joke,
like a Saturday night live skit.
He's like,
okay,
last time.
Same question,
and he kept on until the guy wouldn't answer the question.
He,
I'll show it to you.
Hold on one.
[inaudible] there's two.
Does he sell it?
Your cranes.
You Persian,
yes.
Oh,
I need to hear that.
Yes.
You always need to hear that whenever someone's accusing somebody while he's
doing that real quick.
And one of your standup specials,
do you talk about that video?
About the horse,
that Mr Hands,
did you ever see the documentary?
They made zoo?
Yeah.
Chose joke.
That's the one chosen joke was about I,
they changed the law.
They changed the law because of that dude's
just crazy.
Dot.
Yeah.
That was just like
seeing these people that being interviewed in speaking about their little
zoophilia or whatever they call it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it was,
wow.
It was sort of a documentary.
It was sort of like a performance documentary where they had actors play roles,
so it wasn't,
yeah,
cause the guy's dead.
You know,
he was in through a lot of it.
Like I think it was a real sneaky way they did that documentary,
but what it did was it forced them to change the law there.
People were moving there so they can fuck animals legally.
That's what these people did.
They met online,
they met in a chat room.
They said,
I like fucking animals.
I'm just going to put that out there.
And then everybody's like,
damn,
I like animals.
Fucking me.
Let's,
let's do this.
Let's move in together.
And they moved in together and they've got like,
you know,
an area where they all lived and they would go to a farm.
And Phil did hundreds of hours of guys getting fucked by donkeys and horses.
Crazy man.
Insane man.
Here's the video right here.
So he just lets you know,
man,
that there's always gonna be someone who's taken a deeper,
I can't answer that question right now.
And,
and when,
why not?
You're referring to mistakes you made.
Have you changed your story from when you spoke to investigators years ago?
I did lie on a report,
uh,
years ago.
And what did you lie about then?
It was just a mess.
I made mistakes,
um,
by not telling the honest truth.
Uh,
in a,
in a police report.
What,
just be specific.
I mean,
we've talked about the broad outlines of the story.
What is it that you were untruthful about?
Just everything that took place that weekend
was the fight between Natalie Wood and her husband,
Robert Wagner.
What ultimately led to her death?
Yes.
How so?
I tell you that you won't buy my book.
Like I said,
that's going to be up to the investigators to decide.
Um,
the point you're making is that it's because of information in the book
information that you're bringing to them that they would be reopening this
investigation.
Is it your charge that in fact Robert Wagner,
uh,
essentially tried to make this a low profile investigation,
did not do everything he could to try to find her once she went missing after
their arguments?
Yes,
it was,
um,
it was to be kept a low profile investor,
a little profile investigation.
So you're saying that Wagner did not do everything he should have done to look
for her after she went missing exactly what she was he responsible for her death
in some way?
Well,
like I said,
I think we all made mistakes that night and um,
Mr that wasn't my question.
Was He responsible for her death?
I'm not asking you about your story.
Um,
yes,
I would say so.
Yes.
How so?
I really don't want to get involved in national television,
sir.
And accused him of something
thing like that,
but not back it up.
Well that's up to the investigators.
That's actually not,
the video is pretty interesting.
Well,
yeah,
he sounds as like,
this is definitely something missing.
Something's ticking when she'd be talking and talking and when she'd be ticking.
Right.
He's awesome.
I mean,
yeah.
That's all he's doing,
right.
He ain't nothing being speculated about that.
It wasn't speculated about the day she went drowned.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
didn't William Shatner,
his wife like turn up drown too?
That was in his pool.
Oh Shit.
Wasn't it in his backyard?
Did John Somebody in a pool?
Yeah.
What happened?
I haven't got nothing to William Shatner.
I think he was out of town.
That's good.
Well,
he did it right.
We're not insinuating anyway or whatever.
Yeah,
that guy.
I'm not buying that.
You have to sometimes explain that to people.
Yeah,
you do.
It's a sad world we live in.
Wow.
When you can say retard without any repercussions,
you don't call unclean.
Sure.
Like I think he's a pretty funny too.
It's hilarious.
Sometimes he says some real outrageous shit,
right?
He gets under people's feathers,
but like he'll say something about like when Kim Jong Il died or something.
And Like I love him cause he just retweets every stupid hateful.
It gets sent to him.
But it's like these people are like really saying like,
how could you say something like that?
It's like,
don't you realize you're following a comedian?
Like sarcastic one at that.
Yeah.
I was like,
it just blows my mind how literal people are.
Yeah.
Well one of the things was a catching news was that he was accusing a will
Ferrell of stealing from him and talking about the really bad bag drugs that
will was doing.
I mean it's just so reads like a Goddamn Collin Quinn punchline,
the really bad,
bad drugs that he was doing,
you know?
And people bought into it.
Man,
it was becoming news.
I can't even dummies you silly fucks.
We,
we live in them to see how quickly,
how many people can drop him or his number will fluctuate.
I look at his number as much as it's too much just because it's funny like who
do you piss off today?
Yeah,
Colin Quinn is im is underappreciated genius.
He's just one of the funniest guys I've ever seen.
Any funny.
When people listen to comedians and then a community and actually has to say
once in a while like,
Yo,
these are jokes.
This is,
we're not serious Collins style of,
of smart ass.
He really smart comedy.
It's so unusual,
man.
I never hardly ever get the sense,
it's hard for us to see each other unless we're like,
you know I,
if I just happen to be in a town where someone's doing a set,
I'll stop in and watch them do a full set or I catch like a special,
but other than that,
you know,
I'm in one town,
they were in another,
it's,
it's hard to see him.
So I did a tough crowd once and there was like one of the first times I got to
see Collin do like a long sat and he did it in front of all of his fans,
you know,
cause they're all so,
so he would like warm up the crowd.
God Damn he was good,
was really good.
Like it's like when you see him tight like t Colin Quinn's a bad motherfucker.
He doesn't get nearly enough respect,
you know,
people that he sold his self deprecating that people just,
I it,
for whatever reason,
I don't know what it is.
I mean he just,
these two smart,
it's whatever it is.
It's his frequencies to,
he's too a,
it's too good for some people to figure out getting a little too dumb.
Really that bad.
I mean,
isn't there a way to snap us out of this man?
One of the things you did a couple of years ago,
I don't know if it was the same special,
but it was about the,
that all the smart people die is that day's coming,
man.
It's possible.
It is possible.
And that's what I thought.
I had a ripped you off a little bit with dead idiocracy a movie maybe,
but it's,
I don't think I'm the only one that's ever had that thought.
I think other people have been thinking that people are getting stupid ass a
little bit.
Yeah.
I ripped off a lot of cords from a lot of songs,
man.
It's not always,
I met Mike Judge.
He didn't seem guilty when I met him,
so he probably didn't make that movie.
I'm just saying this seems like something like,
oh,
this thing's kind of like that premise.
I should've got that special ed earlier.
Actually the special was out before idiocracy my point I,
that's what I'm saying,
especially down in 2005 idiocracy was 2006 but I had been doing that bit for a
couple of years.
That bid came from one mushroom trip,
one mushroom trip.
I just sat and looked at the whole progression of,
of the human race and it was some sort of a crazy fight between overpopulation
of stupid people and like packets of really intelligent people figuring out
matter itself to the point of total complete complexity where they blow up the
whole universe when we restart all over again,
but that all came from a mushroom trip.
Then I started thinking about like how ridiculous it was that I put all my
faith,
my food,
that the warmth and the cold of my family all in the hands of things that I
totally don't understand.
I just hit switches.
I haven't researched them.
I don't know what the fuck powers them.
I have no idea of the science behind it.
I don't know.
I'm just open the frigerator.
It takes some melt pour glass.
I don't know how to fuck this.
Milk has been able to sit in my refrigerator for a week and not turn into rotten
cheese.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but it's been pulverized who?
Some crazy machine that I'll never be able to understand.
Gotten to the point where all the bacteria has broken down so you could store it
in your frigerator that you don't understand some box that keeps shit cold and
that's the only way we can all live like this.
The only way we can all live like this and nobody understands it.
And then I just had that,
you know?
Then the bit just sort of wrote itself.
I tell everybody,
everybody's like,
you gets on these tangents about nuclear bombs and,
and even viruses,
which is perfectly logical,
but I'm saying the real alls it really would take would be let the lights go out
for a week and let's see where we are as,
as a civilization when everything stops working.
Yeah.
Well when it's not good man,
you know,
a person's real true character comes out in a,
in a situation where everything gets tested and a lot of people never get
tested.
They just never get tested to their life.
They coast through the boring but easy job and they go to sleep and they get up
and they do it all over again and the shit never hits the fan.
And if shit does it,
the fans,
when you need to know how to shoot a deer,
you shot the deer,
right?
What do you do now?
You find it now.
How far did it run?
Can you follow the blood trail and what's okay?
You wait,
you,
you shot it.
You found it.
It's dead.
Okay.
Even though,
right?
Got It.
Quarter it.
How do you keep the meat?
Good.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Meets only good for a few hours,
man.
When are you going to do,
unless you get it cut up,
right?
Yeah.
You've got to cut it out and get an a frigerator name.
It's nuts,
man.
The A,
the process is so simple.
Now we go to a supermarket,
it's like we've accelerated everything to the point where it's ridiculous.
You can get meat
like that and you know you could,
well,
no.
Who would've ever thought that you could just step out into the street,
walk a block and get a fucking fat,
thick,
juicy ribeye steak.
Perfectly cut.
Like perfectly aged,
right.
Ready to go.
You'd have do no preparation whatsoever.
Just say,
I'll take that.
Boom.
You take it home.
There's fire,
boom,
you're cooking it in like seconds and an Indian patient is nuclear like
technology right there in your kitchen ready to cook your food.
Yeah,
you can microwave the fuck out of it as he did then.
Right?
It's amazing.
It's amazing what we've come to.
It's such a short period of human history.
We,
you know,
they lead the technology man.
Do you think so?
I'm sure it's me.
I got it in my body,
man.
Part Alien.
Now,
do you believe in aliens for rails again,
one of those things that I just,
I put up to there was like,
I can't not believe in aliens.
Right?
I can't sit here and tell you.
I know there's aliens and I've seen it,
but it's like,
all right,
every one of those lights up there is a sun.
Odds are,
there's gotta be,
you know,
another,
another branch of a intelligence.
It just seems ridiculous to think that there wouldn't be,
it seems,
it seems like we've already figured out that things are recreated.
All of the galaxies,
like a glass gas giants,
rocky planets,
planets in the goldilocks zone,
planets with water plants without water.
Like we can apparently read their atmosphere somehow or another.
They can figure that shit out.
I don't know how,
but they could figure out like what temperature a planet is.
Thousands of light years away.
It's a strange,
strange thing.
I don't know how the fuck they do it,
but they found a lot of planets like this a lot.
So there's gotta be some other shit.
Has gotta be some other shit.
So 100%
I mean,
and then you know,
you get into the whole interdimensional speaking of,
you know,
how you,
what if we're dealing with dimensional specs,
you know,
your brain could blow up.
You know,
you gotta be high to think about something.
it's funny,
but we,
we will,
all we do by ridiculing any of that shit is just,
we're just trying to control reality too.
Even the ridiculous part that we understand as is the ridiculous part of us
being a part of a galaxy.
And that galaxy,
a part of the universe is university.
In one part of one universe.
This infinite amount of universes,
like just all these nutty,
nutty that we know to be true.
Like wrapping our heads around infinity and the ideas.
We know that to be true.
We,
we don't want to go any further than that.
You start introducing new shit,
you start introducing aliens,
but
I got no room.
I've got no room for you.
Crazy alien and talk.
It's like there's almost like the reality that we're absorbing as it is,
is so baffling and so fucking crazy that we're like almost unwilling to look at
anything that's more confusing,
not to mention it,
you know,
then the powers that be have also mix this magical thing called religion into
the,
into the fat and to the whole thing.
So if a,
if a ship full of aliens actually came and landed in full view of everybody,
that fucks up a lot of people's belief systems.
Yeah,
that's over.
It really does.
You know what I mean?
It would be interesting,
like who would like jockey first to try to get cool with the aliens?
Like the Catholic Church.
The aliens have made peace.
And you know,
next thing you know is Jesus was an alien.
He was the first and true and only alien.
You know what I mean?
Because this whole war of like they drop off a new gospel.
Yeah,
they bring us a new gospel.
It's a floating USB.
All the other religions are to be wiped out.
That would be so easy.
Matt,
could you imagine if you were from another planet and you had some super dope
technology and you want to come out and you knew the history of the religions,
okay.
What's the number one religion?
Most popular is a Christianity.
Islam.
It's one of those,
okay,
well this is what we do and we're going to come down with one guy that has both
of those religions in his history and he's going to do some fucking magic and
he's going to take over the planet.
There you go.
That's all you'd have to do.
Not even magic to them.
Not even levitating.
That's natural.
That can do that.
Kim Maginnis landing a helicopter a thousand years ago.
Just going back and landing a fucking helicopter and seeing people freak out and
run for cover.
You know what?
What are,
what kind of a world are we going to be living in and just another decade just
to know that 20 years,
it's just another 50,000 years.
You could have just broke out a flashlight and got that.
Yeah.
No Shit.
The finest contained his magic.
Yeah.
Everybody had fire.
That's what they had for fo for,
we told them that was cutting edge technology right there,
man.
A fire and a night.
You were good.
You were caught up with the Joneses.
Why?
Because electricity is only like a couple of hundred years old.
Right.
What's the woman's electricity was eating late 18 hundreds Tesla,
right.
That was the beginning of the next level.
Maybe not even until the early 19 hundreds yeah.
Wow.
That's amazing.
They were using fire to state.
They keep things lit.
If he wasn't angles and shit in the city kites to charge their phones.
That really makes like,
like Leonardo Davinci,
like some of his shit.
Even more impressive that he did that shit by candlelight.
You know,
thinking about the Sistine Chapel.
They can doing that shit with candles.
You know,
God damn motherfucker had fire.
He was lit by fire and he was still motivated enough to do that on his back for
his back.
However many years,
Jesus Christ.
How long did that take?
I don't know how to take a couple of years.
That's one of the great artworks of humankind.
No longer.
I'm sure I'm underestimating.
Keep matching them with all the other dudes who were like trying to be artists
back in the days of Leonardo Da Vinci.
Guys like thought they were pretty bad ass.
You know,
it's,
you know Morgan on,
it's pretty cool pieces.
Pretty proud of it.
You know,
I think I'm kind of the Shit and you,
oh yeah.
You knew that Leonardo Da Vinci Dude.
Yeah.
He's been painting the ceiling for three years.
Yeah,
on his back.
It shits brilliant.
They didn't fit in the helicopter in his spare time in figuring out how to make
a fucking biplane.
It was on speed.
He's amazing,
dude,
man.
He's talking about
super dude.
You know what,
what an amazing mind that guy had wished it was film of that guy.
You know,
he's one of those guys you wish like,
man,
we really missed out on getting some recordings of that guy talking on my
podcast.
He must have been a super genius.
I mean he must've been some insane through the roof Iq type character and he
just,
it seemed like he would like just sketch all these like insane machines out and
figure things out.
And then perfect anatomy.
I mean,
you know,
just what a,
what an amazing,
amazing mind that guy must have had.
Do you ever draw or do any kind of art?
Oh,
I mean a little bit.
I came into music actually I was a graffiti writer,
like with a bunch of cats and some of them started making some music for fun and
I,
I had kind of followed suit and it just became,
you know,
something that happened.
You know,
they have somebody within that group,
new ice tea and that's how that whole thing took off.
Ice t signed me.
But,
um,
I don't make as much art is that must be pretty fucking cool to get signed by
ice tea.
Yeah.
When I was 17
severe like holy shit,
I just got signed by ice.
Tea's amazing.
And it was what it was before.
Like people,
it wasn't like about in a note,
there were no super duper hundred million records selling people in rap.
It was like,
you know,
the biggest people were like run DMC at that time.
Wow.
Uh,
not that public enemy in a few,
you know,
stuff like that.
It was just starting to crack and then,
uh,
I was just doing it for fun and dude asked me if I wanted to make a record for
him and I said sure.
Yeah,
why not?
And I made a record for him and
next thing was house of Payne and whatnot,
but to ask me questions,
I collect a lot of art.
I don't really,
you do collect I,
I'm a,
I'm a avid like graffiti based and street art based collector of art.
Yeah.
I love that.
There's a website for,
I think it's e s t.
Y I think it is.
What it is,
something like that.
But it's a four artists and a lot of our listeners who are artists,
we'll sell like posters on this website.
And lately I've been,
uh,
lately I've been just buying up so much like posters,
like original prints,
cause it's like one out of 20,
we're only printing out 20 pieces of this.
And so for 15 bucks I'll just,
all right,
I'll have one of those 15 or one of his 20 and now I'm just out of nowhere,
it started collecting art because of this one website.
It's amazing website.
Yes.
T I believe
I started out like,
I don't know,
10 years or so,
maybe more ago,
maybe 15 years ago,
collecting all these toys out of Hong Kong that these graffiti writers
from America,
we're going like all these Asian cats,
we're big fans of the whole graffiti scene.
And they would hire these cats to make toys for like companies like bounty
hunter and Metacam and all these.
So I collected all these toys and then I ran into her homie that was like the
editor of a,
of a art magazine called juxtapose.
And,
uh,
he was like,
Yo,
this is cool.
You collect these toys,
but he's like,
you should be actually collecting paintings in an art.
And I was like,
okay.
And the next thing I knew,
I was like,
you know,
going out of it became,
I'm like an obsessive,
I have,
I have like a thousand pairs of sneakers.
I like having a whole,
what's your,
what's your brands of them aren't even open?
Most of them.
Like
I got like 200 pairs of sneakers probably that I just rotate.
Wow.
You know what I mean?
That I'd wear and then there's probably like six,
800 pairs of sneakers.
Like in boxes.
Like I had a whole thing at the Grammy Museum.
They had a hip hop exhibit,
like all my sneeze,
like top 50 sneakers,
sneakers.
Well,
what I'm explaining is like,
I go well for,
for cat like me and wrapped like this,
there's a whole like,
um,
I can,
I'm what I call a w I consider myself a bboy.
Right.
Which is like,
you know,
in the truest sense of the word is a break boy,
a cat that break dancers.
But it became like the,
the the title,
if you're a hip hop like console or like
that I consider myself to be and that's how I live a B boy.
Like you know,
like a,
like a Hesher would be a rock dude.
A bboy is hip hop sat question.
That's how it would be.
Asher is to rock cause B boy his third base they will be bboys sure,
definitely.
But collected sneakers is kind of part of that sneaker.
It's part of the culture.
I agree.
I you,
I could be in some dirty clothes if I had done a new piece of jewelry and some
new sneakers.
You can't tell me nothing.
You have a favorite brand.
Yeah,
but like I'm pretty much a Nike Snob,
you know like old school air force ones and Jordans and stuff like that.
But did you get the Voltron's?
I haven't.
I stopped collecting a couple of years ago.
I still buy sneakers,
but I forced myself to wear them all.
Like,
I ha I don't buy,
I used to buy compulsively just to be like if I,
I don't even know if I like those but could a moment.
So do you have like a closet that's specially designed for sneakers?
That bedroom that no,
it's not designed.
It's just looks like a backroom storage spot of a footlocker.
It's kind of crazy.
Really?
Yeah,
it's retarded.
I won't even show it anymore cause it's shameful.
Shameful.
But the point I,
the reason I even brought it up though is that I'm compulsive like that after I
was doing the sneakers and I,
like I said I collected these toys but I stopped doing both of those.
I kind of sick all that energy into collecting like paintings.
I have like paintings now in,
in how I,
I have a couple of different houses.
I have paintings like just that there's too many even hanging on walls,
they're like in stacks just laying on the,
on against leaning up against walls or you should give tours.
Man.
I bet you have some amazing shit or do it.
Little video blog for your website.
There's a lot of cats that are blowing up really big right now that I've had for
a long time.
Cause and shepard Fairey I was collecting before she was,
you know,
like bank Banksy,
you know all,
you know Jose Parla.
Yeah.
Just and all kinds of this,
I'm big on a cat name.
Crayola,
Greg symptons.
It's a big time pain,
you know what I mean?
It's all,
everything it future,
uh,
all cast like that.
But everything's based around graffiti or street art,
like cats.
That actually started like industry's putting their art up.
It has awesome.
I went to this dude's house
once you had a house in the Hollywood hills and uh,
he had a whole wall of his house.
Like we had a crazy house with a glass wall that faces the city,
you know,
the whole deal.
And a whole,
like long wall of his house was a gallery.
It was set up like four rotating pieces of art.
And he would,
you know,
literally like harbor some of the best artists in the world and buy their shit
and rotate new stuff from their tos.
Like he had warehouses where it would store pieces that he wasn't showing.
I'm getting to the point where I have to find like a professional place soon to
store a lot of my art.
Yeah.
This dude had his house set up like a museum.
I mean he would wrote him.
He's incredibly,
incredibly rich.
The House I was telling you about up here in the hills before I had a kid and
got married,
that's all it was.
The downstairs of the house had no furniture.
It was just paintings all around.
Let me ask you something.
Well,
living in the house,
cause I,
I've had friends that were robbed up there.
I've had a couple of friends that have been coming here up in the Hollywood
hills,
Hollywood hills.
Oh,
you're talking about Yup.
Here.
Yeah.
But the Hollywood hills is what I was talking about.
Like I,
I've heard a lot of people getting like home invasions of shit in the Hollywood
hills.
Sure.
Man,
you get caught slipping.
I mean,
I used to live in Mount Olympus actually,
which is right up here in Laurel Canyon and,
and I lived up there for many years and never had a problem.
But I'm that dude dead when he's driving home from the store,
like has the gun in his lap and I make two extra turns on that.
Dude.
I just,
that's awesome.
It's not because I'm on this thing that everybody's out to get me,
but it's like I'm not going to beat the guy to get got because I was stupid and
I just been trained like that.
But I owe that to like actually a lot of like Cypress homeys and them cats when
we was all coming up together cause they kind of came,
I came from suburbia,
you know what I mean?
Not Rich Suburbia,
you know,
lower class,
lower middle class but middle class nonetheless.
And these cats came from,
you know like I was with ice and all them,
like I ran with the syndicate for awhile but I never was like dipped into like
he was already a grown man into the entertainment business is big gangster.
And all that days were right behind him.
Cypress guys were fresh off the street,
you know what I mean?
Like when they first made that first record.
So I learned a lot from them about like how to roll like places and Yo,
they were always worried about who was following them when they were leaving.
So it kind of,
even though it didn't apply to me,
always,
it's stuck with me to be that alert about things.
And also because I tend to wear a lot of jewelry.
I have a,
I have a really nice car,
you know what I mean?
The sucker that it,
constant paranoia almost like you're at olive garden.
Know,
like I said,
I'm not like everybody's out to get me,
but it's like,
let me just be sure of who I am and where I am and what's what's around me,
you know what I mean?
So I'll make that extra turn.
I'll make that.
If I,
and I,
and I've,
I've been lucky long enough to think that luck is,
I don't,
you know,
I really don't believe in luck.
It's just a word that you use because if,
if there was such thing as luck,
you know,
you could fuck a pig and actually have a real kid,
you know what I mean?
Like that'd be,
that would be magic.
More broadly.
He lucky.
It'd be lucky.
I don't believe in magic.
So,
but it's Matt Luckiest Magic to a certain degree.
That's my point in a way.
In a weird way what I'm saying.
It's like I've been alert enough that I know that I have actually avoided a few
times of actually beings robbed or this or that and the other by just by
circumstances and how I reacted to them and how I was alerted to them.
There was times when I was in New York at certain clubs where I've definitely
knew I was being,
I was being like stalked and about to be preyed upon.
And I would happen to bump into some cats that I knew and I'd be like,
I'm already alerted to these dudes w you know?
And it'd be like,
just the fact that now with some people's,
I know and then I,
they know I'm on to them.
You know what I mean?
You're by yourself.
If you,
if you ain't getting your oblivious,
I mean like it's,
you know,
that's the,
that's the worst thing is being oblivious to what's going on around you.
That is a crazy thing.
You have to worry about people physically jacking you.
Dude,
I'm not going to come on everybody.
You don't think about it all.
But I mean like it's a thing that we have to worry about it so real.
I made a lot of music and all that but my profile is nowhere near yours.
You know what I mean?
I've sold a lot of records,
whatever.
I keep a low profile on purpose.
I like going to Ralph's.
I like it.
I like going into the olive bar and making my own little bowl of olives.
I like that.
I enjoy that.
I like getting a little blue box of cheezits and some olives and going home and
watching whatever it is does UFC or a football game,
whatever.
I like to be able to do that.
I like to be able to drive my car and enjoy it.
Right.
I mean,
so I keep my,
my music is far more famous than I am as a face.
You got to work,
you're the face of a sport to a certain degree.
So it's like your most bottles.
Very nice to me.
Most people are decent,
nice people.
We're not worried about those people.
It's true table.
We're worried about the small percentage that are nice.
Yeah.
He,
you had a public uh,
online battle with m and M and,
and I know this is old and everything like that,
but a lot of us followed it.
Uh,
I didn't find out about it until today.
Is that right?
Yeah,
it was,
it was a very,
I mean,
amongst us it was known in our fans.
It was known but it wasn't like,
it was like this thing over Napster.
Like I never released a record about it because I wasn't trying to profit off
the situation.
It was a personal thing between me and him.
What'd you guys get mad at each other for?
I got a little mad at him cause I went to shake his hand somewhere and he kind
of,
before he was m and m who he is now Elvis,
you know,
the as big as Elvis type character.
This was like when he was first coming in and I just went to shake his hand and
he kind of,
I felt disrespected,
found out later that,
you know,
he didn't really see it the same way.
He didn't realize it was that kind of situation after the fact.
Like I said,
we haven't had a problem for 10 years.
Right.
So it's just a short little thing or like words,
words,
words.
And then it was like,
you know,
it was just,
just became like,
all right,
well you know,
you don't talk about me,
we won't talk about you and we'll just keep it at that.
One of the things that I've found,
and it's pretty easy to,
to to grab upon this,
is that whenever you're around anybody who's really creative or really out there
really like dynamic and the way they perform,
they're also almost always very emotional,
you know?
And some of them have a good handle on it.
Like you,
you know,
you're always a pretty relaxed,
mellow in a certain groove.
Dude,
you're never like,
I've been around you a bunch of times.
I never seen you like agitated and never seen you like stress in about anything.
You're always,
you know,
you,
you maintain a certain pace.
Some people would really just can't do that.
You know?
Also,
I'm not,
there's no show.
I told you,
I said it earlier in the show.
I've been faking it for years,
man.
I'm just trying to figure,
I'm making music.
I don't even know how to make music.
I don't even know.
You know,
this is,
all of this is luck and icing and as much as I feel like,
Yo,
I'm listening to this what I'm meant to do,
you know,
I feel like it to a degree,
it's what it's meant to do.
It's a lot of luck.
Do you guys do,
you know,
is that you feel personally or as smart as you and as talented as you that for
one reason or another without being like,
they didn't get convicted of rape or nothing stupid like that,
but just it just,
something doesn't click.
Like something doesn't happen for them.
And it's like I got a bunch of musician friends of mine that are geniuses that
I'm just like,
why?
Why?
What is it about them?
Why,
why,
what that element is,
whatever.
That planets lining up that just you're at the right place,
right time and you know how to react.
You know what I mean?
I agree to we all.
We all are responsible for our fates.
I believe I made a choice somewhere along the line.
It contributed to what I'm doing.
It's not just blind luck,
but there's,
there's,
that's an element in the,
in the thing you could have all the other things,
the talent,
the drive,
the w,
the work ethic,
and if that one.